[Music]
with major blockbusters and huge
franchises taking up most of our
attention these days it can be easy to
lose track of all the great releases
sneaking by under the radar but these
2018 fantasy movies are well worth
seeking out for his feature directorial
debut Anders Walter has successfully
brought Joe Kelly's graphic novel I
killed I ants to life resulting in a
mesmerizing tale of heartache and
heroism the plot follows Barbara Thorson
a restless 12-year old girl living on
Long Island who in an effort to escape
from her turbulent home life takes on a
unique kabhi slaying Giants Giants
Altria very sweaty as the film follows
Barbara through her adventures it
beautifully weaves together childhood
heartache and thrilling escapism along
with an epic dose of fantasy action with
solid directing acting and CGI this
all-around high quality feature has a
kind of Pan's Labyrinth feel to it and
is bound to appeal to your inner giant
slayer although most blockbusters are
plenty of fun and full of eye candy
there's still something special about a
well-made movie that didn't have access
to mountains of cash case in point
Justin Benson and Aaron Moore heads the
endless and not quite sequel to their
first movie resolution the duo directed
shot and starred in the film delivering
a shocking fantasy Tinch story of uneasy
fear which we'll discomfort even the
most stalwart horror fan the film
storyline follows Justin and Aaron Smith
as they return to the mysterious cult
they once escaped once they're the
unnatural peace is slowly and
masterfully broken down in a series of
Revelations that expose a horrific
Lovecraftian underbelly hey trio going
away again Wow thank you that's honest
tastefully terrorizing the endless blunt
elements of fantasy sci-fi and horror
all without the advantages of a huge
budget or a list actors not that this
stop the film from attracting near
Universal critical acclaim how do you
think you gained telekinetic powers
obviously by drinking water from a
mountain spring hit by a meteor at least
that's what treinta Poussin's director's
saying hoyeon
had in mind when he made one of the most
refreshingly unusual superhero movies of
the year written and directed by yeon
psychokinesis is a good reminder that
superhero movies don't have to be about
saving the world
the story is inwardly focused following
the origin of the unlikely hero Sookie
on an ordinary man who accidentally
gains telekinetic powers this all
happens just in time to receive a
distress call from as estranged daughter
Remini informing him that a mob run
construction company is threatening her
trendy fried chicken restaurant and Sol
launched into the action as he's still
just getting to grips with his own
abilities so kyon comes across as a
perfectly legitimate superhero
frustrated by his own powers and often
unable to think on his feet simple and
refreshingly light it's a superhero
movie of down-to-earth proportions and a
welcome change of pace in a Marvel and
DC dominated world before the turn of
the millennium director Terry Gilliam
set out to film an adaptation of miguel
de cervantes classic 1615 novel Don
Quixote his attempts to do so became the
stuff of Hollywood legend as Gilliam
battled through a seemingly endless
series of production delays actor
turnovers and legal in financial
Fiasco's his journey even inspired its
own documentary 2002's lost in La Mancha
which followed the futility of an early
go-around on the project that featured
Johnny Depp as Sancho Panza but
Gilliam's vision for his comically
romanticized film was set with gritty
determination and decades later the
movie has finally arrived in the form of
the man who killed Don Quixote the
film's plot progresses through an absurd
and fantastic series of events with Adam
driver playing a simple yet perfect foil
to Jonathan prices wide-eyed ludicrously
charming shoemaker who believes he is
the real Don Quixote it's a fun movie
with a great story behind it which only
serves to make it that much more
interesting to watch if you're just as
much of a fan of romantic comedies as
you are of a good shocking twist or two
you're going to want to check out when
we first met the story follows Noah a
man who falls in love with a woman named
Avery after the to spend an evening
romping around in a near-perfect
date-like series of fun adventures which
ends with a soul-crushing Lea friendly
hug as time goes on noah pines for his
lost love until he stumbles into a
fantastical photo booth that sends him
back in time to the day they met this
sets off a hilarious series of try and
try again scenarios in which noah
attempts to change his personality in
order to create the perfect first date
and when Avery over before she could
meet her future fiance Ethan they're
like love magnets and no matter what
happens
we're gonna smash into each other over
and over and over and over I get it
you're extremely threatened by Ethan
when we first met has a clear-cut
Groundhog Day feel to it but Adam
Devine's ingratiating energy saves the
movie keeping the story light and the
audience laughing
[Music]